the first thing is there has to be a
movement I'm not here like this much my
body don't don't deviate just home swoon
so wait the movements coming in slower
and you see my body start to shape
itself not my body is starting to shape
itself you see and I'm gonna go around
the contingent just like kind of end go
attention point and I am going to go
around it so the same thing body starts
to shape itself and I let that go around
this is not it
[Music]
don't start so far away time here and he
starts to go body shapes itself so my
body is doing that boom and I'm cutting
not here see that difference body shapes
shape and 10.com oh in the middle okay
so don't wait for me to grab you and
you're already moving see not like this
my body is already moving in in in a
relationship with it okay shake your
body you see that no here no here Yin
you see so don't wait boom boom so I got
two shapes here you see see the shoulder
not like this he's going to hit it hard
bone so shape it and pull them into the
knife then you got a second shape here
so just watch my body give you that boom
boom don't miss please okay oh you guys
see that not like this
shake my body manahan's in the fight Oh
slower one slower one you see too
[Music]
shape
I want to take the principle of
Tymoshenko and start applying it in a
more sophisticated way so when he's
coming in right that's that's the first
one and I'm going to try to do as little
movement as possible so I don't want to
take one two three four no one actually
let's see if I can still find the in
space right is that in space and don't
miss me boom in my body shape yes
because I wanted him to come in and hit
the knife I don't want him to go out
here DC he's gonna come in and hit the
knife
so he wants that oh and he wants to
secure me do you understand so I have to
I want to use that so you space boom I
wanted neck to hit the knife so to stop
trying to get way off the line see if
you don't have to get off line but
you're not clashing mmm okay so Yin
absorb
the knife exchange like all weapons
they're trying to teach you something
that you'll body art it's not as good as
when it comes to teaching okay so I
don't want those vectors I'm not
supposed to have them in my body art but
you do when you have them with the knife
it becomes obvious that it's a dumb
thing to do
same thing goes with when I go to the
knife though you guys will tend to stop
so I come in right and then I'm here do
you see see how my spine stops he comes
in and I don't want to stop him so he's
coming in boom he should not stop at my
house we can go slow but I'm gonna have
in Indian oh I want to see his spine
teeth moving so that the fluidity of the
knife will influence my mind to be fluid
so you can go slow but I want you as
noggin to make sure that his spine keeps
traveling across the mat you understand
that so same thing with him if he stops
himself the other attack is going to be
there so we're gonna work together slow
and smooth taking the fluidity
there's the yen fool
I want the knife to keep moving I want
him to keep moving okay doing geometry
right and using it for custody okay
when you grab look I broke my di angry
so I you want to touch that you see I
have a karate going you understand you
get some not here like this there's a
karate good
percussive boom right into the carotid
all right and then check it's right you
see I'm doing that and then I find my
mark
boom so yen boom pop percussive boom
right into the garage check his height
so check his height by dropping your
elbow for my elbow good down here
dad's gonna tighten this rod into so
miss miss boom percussive boom I get to
it Hey